نحن هنا على الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان
بالتزامن مع مناورات عسكريه اسرائيليه
تحاكي اندلاع حرب متعدده الجبهات فان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يبقي على حال تاهب قصوى
على الجبهه الشماليه مع لبنان وقد اخبر
سكان البلدات والمستوطنات الحدوديه بامكان
ان تندلع حرب قريبا وضروره اجلاء السكان
منها رغم ان المراقبين يستبعدون حدوث ذلك
قريبا لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل
التدريبات والتهديدات بامكان اندلاع
مواجهه مع حزب الله وهنا ايضا داخل مزارع
شبعه المحتله يسود التوتر شديد بين
الجيشين الاسرائيلي واللبنان بسبب حفر
اسرائيل لخنادق في تلك المنطقه لكن الصوره
تبقى اعقد واكثر تركيبا بكثير اسرائيل
تتحرك وكان الحرب على الابواب لانها تدعي
بان ايران توشك على اخفاء البرنامج النووي
الايراني بعمق كبير تحت الجبال بحيث يصبح
منيعا وحصينا امام الضربات حتى امام
القنابل الذكيه الخارقه للتحسينات
الامريكيه ما يعني ان هذه العمليه
العسكريه يجب ان تكون سريعه وهندد التفكير
بذلك يتم التفكير بامكان ان تندلع حرب
شامله على الجبل الشماليه زياد حلبي
العربيه محيط مزارع شبح لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات